what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here today I'm gonna watch the
introducing atom trailer for injustice -
I'm a big fan of oh my god what's his
name the Ray Palmer actor from Superman
Returns what's his name John it's not
Christopher Reeves not Henry Cavill it
is Brandon
ralphe ralphe which has nothing to do
with this because he's not in the game
make sure I got my facts right about
that yeah so I was like yeah I'll watch
this trailer because I like I like the
atom character a lot and here we are in
today's page from the day shout-out is
gonna go to none other than Tony Mick
Dwyer
[Music]
[Music]
Adams Adams
nice
oh man you know I I love playing this
game I haven't beat the story mode yet
whenever I go over to Tony's place Tony
Gill it's in the gamer tree Z on
Instagram every time I go over there we
always end up versing each other and
injustice for at least two hours trying
to beat one another he usually beats me
I'm not as good as him at the game Adam
looks like the exact kind of character I
would love to get good at with using but
I feel like I would suck at figuring out
how to do all the cool stuff that Adam
can do it's fun seeing him here I wish
we saw a little bit more of his
personality that's what I like when they
do these introduction trailers is when
you get to see the kind of dialog they
have the way they have their little
minor cutscenes they have before the
fight or after the fight so I wish we
got a little bit more of that because I
really love the Ray Palmer personality
but it's pretty cool seeing him in here
it looks a little more like cartoony
huge compared to like a lot of the other
injustice characters a lot of his moves
look pretty sweet all the expected
abilities of the shrinking and growing
abilities that he has and the flying cat
looks awesome shrinking and growing
hey hey hey John I said shrinking and
growing no I don't have one of those now
much more you could really say other
than patron the day shoutout for a Tony
McGuire he is a recent patron and Tony I
want you to know I ordered the shirt for
you that the reward tier offers and we
will sign that for you and get it over
to you Tony
actually has a big passion for gaming
and that's why I wanted to give him a
shout-out here don't really know the guy
incredibly well just yet but Tony if
there's one thing I know is that when
you first message me the first day we
talked I thought your name was actually
Tobey Maguire and I didn't want to make
fun of you there cuz I'm like a lot of
people I've probably already said Tobey
Maguire so many time
and you know people hear my name they go
to Joe's a good and I think they're a
bunch of freaking idiots so I didn't
want you to feel the same way then I saw
your name was actually Tony Nook Dwyer
and then I realized all those thoughts I
have or irrelevant you're in Colorado
right now you have a passion for gaming
if there's one thing I know is that
gamers flourish in Colorado that's where
the major industry is that I hope that
you can continue sitting around not
doing much with your life and playing
video games
just like how I sit around don't do much
of my life and talk to a camera I hope I
can be your inspiration anyway guys
subscribe to the reel rejects and click
that notification bill might come in
handy one day